after a few months of email exchanges
one day martha invited me
to their home in ohio she said hey
we know you like america why don't you
come
and visit us for one month and we will
take care of all
your expenses this video isn't about me
it's about opportunity this video isn't
about
us it's about opportunities
from a juvenile where my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro was picky to the night east
moschino and versace no laces in iraqis
new millennium
sisters and dear friends welcome on many
times you've seen on this couch
he drives in on this side i'm seeing on
the right side doing separate videos
well today this couch has brought us
together yeah not in a literal sense
well in the literal sense why you know
the premiere
today i've got a very interesting video
um and it was actually recommended to me
because i think you've done a video
about
brother ness yeah so here's a youtube
channel called nasty he started on
facebook he moved on to the youtube
scene
i came across a very interesting video
because i've kind of i didn't know who
he was
uh but his he was brought into our
attention in a face uh what's up group
and there was a discussion about isiah
muslim and i was thinking i don't know
he jumped on a video about the dean on
the dean show
and um there were some points that he
brought that you clarified for him
um but i was curious is he muslim or not
so then i went on to
youtube and i wrote nasty muslim and
then i came across a few of his videos
and he said people think i'm a bad
muslim
i was going to do a reaction video to
that but then i thought i found a very
interesting video and this video is
called
um opportunities yeah and i think i
haven't seen this
you haven't seen it but um i've seen it
and it's worth
watching and reacting to it because it's
probably nasty i'm sure he's going to be
watching this
if he can wash it with an open heart
genuinely brother if you're watching
this please
do not see this as we criticize you you
know this is with points and figures we
genuinely want you to just
watch it with an open mind because i
found that very video of opportunity
inspiring but we want to look at it from
another angle
you ready yep okay
almost 11 years ago i got that help
an american woman from ohio named
martha was invited by my english teacher
to come to our classroom and teach us
english for one hour she came as a
volunteer
every year to villages like mine
to teach english and when she walked
through that door
she was the first american i met in my
life
immediately i fell in love with her and
her family
immediately i connected with her son and
we became
email buddies pen pal please
after a few months of email exchanges
one day martha invited me
to their home in ohio she said hey
we know you like america why don't you
come
and visit us for one month and we will
take care of
all your expenses
this was the first opportunity in my
life to go and explore the united states
i jumped on that opportunity
one now i want to just pick up on a few
things he talks about opportunity he
talks about how happy he is that
a human being gave him an opportunity
to go to america or even maybe
apply harvard university now he's over
the moon with this yeah
now from his videos he seems like he's a
youtuber that travels around the world
yeah
and he's called nas daily now i want to
use this name that i use it for himself
and say
nas daily you have an opportunity every
single day
given to you by allah by god now before
you say oh
here we go again religion just hear us
out because why i wanted to touch upon
his life as human beings
when somebody does something for us we
over the moon like how can we pay that
guy back you know he did this for me and
he did that for me or that
um sister to a sister brother so brother
you know you get overwhelmed that you
want to show your utmost
gratitude and be ready to on the call if
they need you etc you know
and he's talking about that opportunity
now
if you've noticed on his shirt yeah he
has a t-shirt right on his t-shirt
he's got 36 percent do you know what
that is
signifying so that's he believes that's
36 36 of his life gone
yeah so what i wanted to highlight is
uh brother and as you travel around the
world yeah
showing gratitude to a human being is
good because what does all the
supernatural say what is it
who said that um the one who doesn't uh
nursely allah whoever doesn't think the
people doesn't thank allah yes that's
fine
but if somebody is thanking human beings
and has the human being's great of
interest and that is good and there's
something that islam promotes
but if he's neglecting his lord because
let's think about it nas daily you do
daily vlogs
daily allah has given you an opportunity
and if you think about it everything
that you are being offered
is through him but if your gratitude is
more to the human beings
then allah do not think that's a point
of reflection
yeah i mean the first thing that allah
says in the quran is alhamdulillah
which is praise and thanks belongs to
allah lord of the worlds and because
if and actually the elephant here the
elephant lemon
it means all praise and all thanks
ultimately goes back to allah because
the ultimate um the ultimate reason for
everything's existence
and for your provision with anything
that you may have
is the creator that that created
everything that does exist
that puts into existence everything that
exists
so our livelihoods our life
i mean like hamsas also says i mean
there's certain things that are
happening to us on a
minute basis that we don't even think
about how many times does the heart beat
and we don't even know about it you know
and we can all be grateful
for at least the heart beating because
there's no human being they'll be
walking on the face of the earth lest
their heart had to be so in and from
that perspective there's always
something to be grateful for
and there's something beautiful that the
prophet muhammad said
is the affair of the believer that all
of his affair is good and this is not
the case for anyone except for the
for the believer he says
if good things happen to him he's
thankful
if bad things happen to him he's he's
also thankful he's
patient and is thankful so thanking is
is this position or something that we do
naturally
and and this is the fitra actually this
is the innate
predisposition that we uh innately
right want to thank um our lord
the one who we recognize automatically
right exactly
for all of those things that we have in
our life and so
he was able to recognize it with martha
yes i'm sure a very generous person
but who is more generous than the most
generous one which is allah exactly and
if you think about the word
is that when when someone buys you a
gift you thank them for what they did
for you
but we thank allah because of his him
deserving the thank god of who he is
not because of the things that he's done
for us that's besides the point if
allowed to do nothing for us
he's still deserving of praise of who he
is now
he might not might come and say i'm far
away from religion he's got a
region where he says people are picking
on him he's bad he's drunk etc
i just want to make a connection with
this statement here one day
martha gave me another opportunity she
said i should go
and visit harvard i didn't know what
harvard was
i thought it was a place that only smart
people go
look we can stop that and say look you
can say the same about the quran
you can say some like we're telling you
aki read the quran give islam a chance
you can say
brothers i don't know i'm like i might
be far away from the religion
i don't know what it is maybe it's for
righteous people yeah look what look
what i said next year look what he goes
he goes
that's only for smart people is jannah
only or is islam
only for the righteous people no i mean
islam is submission to one god right
and so allah says in the quran
be completely submissive to allah
basically go
into submission fully that's what it
says go into submission fully
and only when you submit yourself
wholeheartedly to the one who created
you and
sustaining you will you really feel the
purpose of life
this is the point really and this is
open access because allah says in the
quran
and if my slave asks you about me
then i am i answer the caller of the
call
call i answer the call of the caller
when he call when he calls
meaning and you know it's really
interesting because in arabic usually
when allah says
when they ask about this say this and
say that
in this construction he didn't even say
say
because he wanted to make the words
closer to each other because he's saying
and if they ask if my slave asked me
about me then i am
he doesn't say say i am to put all the
words closer together
it shows you that you know the very
precise nature of the quran
you know i answer the caller of the qu i
answer the quote of the quran when he
calls
so if anybody asks allah
for guidance whether they are muslim or
not whoever they
are allah will answer that because allah
says
that to un to us is guidance in other
words if
anybody comes at the door of god allah
will answer that call that's a promise
from allah subhanahu
see same thing don't ever think i'm a
sinner i'm not good enough i can
i can never don't ever because we come
from i'm a revolution i come from
jahiliyyah you know there's other
brothers who may have come don't ever
say to yourself
i'm not good enough just as the way you
look at harvard and said i'm not smart
they won't accept me
i don't know allah and his messenger is
telling you allah is the most merciful
any time at your stage turn to him
inshallah let's carry on
she didn't listen to me she flew me from
ohio
to boston to go meet her son eli
who's a student at harvard why did you
send me there
because i thought you were really smart
and i thought it'd be interesting for
you to
see it i didn't know that you'd end up
going there
but i thought you could apply there i
thought your person's perfectly capable
of applying them possibly getting it
and when i landed on campus as a tourist
my world changed people were not as
smart as we think
they were normal people like you and me
well
that's that's profound as well
you know imagine entering gender and you
see people there and you may know
some people who were like yo that guy
used to sin a lot my mother think what's
this guy doing in paradise
but there are people who sin but
repented
you know so to think that jannah is only
for the righteous no
there are people who will be their
sinning in us yeah
sinners and we allah the best of sinners
are those who repent
so don't ever think to yourself you
don't belong there you're far from it
i'm gone don't this is the works of
shaytan so watching this video of
opportunity
we want to hand the opportunity to you
that allah has given
to us on a daily basis to convey this
message to you inshallah and let's carry
on inshallah that
inspired me i flew back home immediately
and bought many books i improved my
english
salmon salmon salmon salmon
i learned well i can i can make a
distinct like with the connection
between that
is many books salmon salmon
salmon tajweed no no but let's be real
i'm just genuinely wanting to make him
think here like you're giving the
dedication to go harder to get all these
books
while i like and i'm not saying you're
not maybe you are
but if you can give like just a bit of
that dedication to islam give me stop a
chance open the quran and
read it you know and it's a reminder to
me well i'm trying to learn the arabic
language and learn how to read the quran
it's never too late and you should do
that don't ever feel because i'm making
a comparison between your dunya
life and the hereafter you can do it one
book not many books yeah
and the telugu of salmon that's not a
problem you know you can even
subhanallah learning
arabic yeah about harvard admission
i studied and studied and studied and a
few months later
i applied and to my surprise
harvard said yes i graduated
with a harvard degree i went to new york
got a really good job
and made money and then i started nas
daily i traveled the world created
videos connected with millions
of people published a book and started
a real company
[Applause]
this video isn't about me
it's about opportunity this video isn't
about
us it's about opportunities yeah and
uh brother nice if you're watching this
inshallah i just want to
reach out to you and say that you can
contact me on brother muhammad
if you want it's an opportunity we have
an opportunity every single day
to change for the better and in your
video you touched upon being a good
what we're not good or bad brother nice
i just wanted to leave you with this
inshallah um i don't know if we're gonna
watch any more of that
um is that look being good if you're
good to the entire globe
if you're good to everybody and you are
bad to your parents are you a good
person
of course not so brother nice imagine
that you're good to the entire world and
you're charitable
but you are bad to the one who's created
you so i'm just saying
that if you are grateful to the people
and opportunities that they have
presented you and you are very thankful
and that is good and that is part of
islam
please for one moment just reflect upon
what allah has given you because allah
is the one who is
giving you these things through these
people inshallah and hopefully
you reflect inshaallah and that's that's
what i think i wanna i don't think
there's anything else to watch
um but yeah that's it the village
kid in me needed opportunity
i needed someone to open the door just a
little bit
to show me the light and i'm so lucky
that someone did that for me my parents
gave me opportunity to be free and
explore what i like
my english teacher jamal assadi gave me
opportunity and invited martha to come
to our english class
and martha's family gave me opportunity
to grow you know well you know you give
people opportunities
and whether or not they take advantage
of it or appreciate it is
it's up to them we're going to leave you
on that brother nas
the opportunities there in front of you
for you to see the signs of allah
and turn to him because all every
opportunity that you have it's from him
and you believe in god and we'll leave
that with you inshallah
you have the choice like martha said she
said something very interesting that
everyone has opportunities it's up on
them to take it or not
and we'll leave it with that inshallah
hijab thank you for your time you know
been here
man i bless you guys bless you
inshaallah and brother now you can get
in contact with us and shall i hope this
benefited you in a positive way
till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi